Of course, any culture in the world has their own superstitions.
Korea has a couple of dating superstitions.
They're wacky.
They're totally not true, but they're tons of fun.
Here's a couple of dating superstitions in Korea.
If you pour your own drink, you'll be single for three years.
If you give your girlfriend or boyfriend shoes as a present,...
...they will leave you or cheat on you.
Also, all men in Korea have to go through the army.
So, if your boyfriend goes to the army and you cry, you'll break up.
Another superstition of breaking up is taking out your wisdom teeth.
In Korea, if you take out your wisdom teeth, you'll break up.
Of course, this is totally not true, but it's fun.